Joe Biden's poll numbers are in deep
doo-doo the latest stinker comes from
CNN where his approval is now just at 39
and 67 a Democrats want to dump him from
the ticket but here's the real kick in
the you know what Biden is struggling
against all his Republican contenders
especially Nikki Haley who is crushing
Joe by six points but some Dems in the
media are trying to put on a happy face
we will win re-election
there is too much at stake and the
American people know it when it comes to
results and performance uh President
Biden has a spectacular uh record
president's doing a great job and how do
I know that I just look at what he has
delivered maybe we don't do a good
enough job messaging uh about things
like the infrastructure Bill and The
Pact act you'd rather have the very
popular policies Biden running on versus
the Republicans who seem to want to
focus on very contentious issues
President Biden's policy agenda is so
popular that Republicans are running on
it what a mess
um
does this help Nikki Haley I mean it
seems like she might have got a bounce
from that debate she did she did in the
polls show that and then in a couple
weeks there's another opportunity I
think there's more money coming into
campaign and then so she's kind of got
the wind at her back right and the other
reason you know that is because
yesterday Biden's team directly hit her
and her alone right so but these numbers
that say Biden is losing to anyone in
the Republican field should mean
probably means that he's softening
within his own party so he has to shore
up his base if he has a prayer to win
re-election and I think that's one of
the reasons you saw the announcement
yesterday about Alaska and canceling oil
and gas leases right because what do
they care about so much right climate
change and they Elizabeth Warren and
others can go on TV and say I know Joe
Biden is terrific because just look at
his list of accomplishments but if they
look at their own polling within the
Democratic party they think he's too old
to run by like 69 and 82 percent of them
said they'd be one willing to look at
somebody else that means that he is not
their favorite right and also Kamala
Harris she wasn't even in the second
tier when they asked Democrats she was
at the bottom they got an issue always
on the bottom judge what
um nothing just say hello what I always
love is whenever there's trouble they
always say it's the messaging and not
the actual policies yeah well I'll tell
you uh the fact is that only five
percent of Voters of democratic voters
say they have zero concerns of the Biden
candidacy to me that just jumped off the
page so that they all have concerns but
they're not ready to guide to kind of
jump away from them although 67 percent
want a different candidate but I think
what CNN did by showing Trump ahead of
Biden and and Nikki Haley as well I
think that it's kind of like an
invitation to the rest of the the
Democratic party look we're admitting
now that Biden can be beat by all these
people maybe it's time for an another
candidate to jump in but I think it
speaks to the authoritarianism of the
Democrat Party that they're like so
locked in with Joe Biden when so many
people are concerned about everything
from his cognitive decline to his age to
and by the way in 2020 I mean he didn't
have all the negatives he has now with
inflation and the consumer issues and
the mortgage rates etc etc and Kamala
being convinced they're going to win
doesn't mean a thing
you know Harold 67 percent want a
different candidate but does it does
that really matter when all you guys
just essentially fall in line come
2024 whatever the next year is you're
talking to me yes Harold I am how could
you look at it Jesse as you I mean I get
you too confused
should I look like AI also yeah yeah
both of you the the amazing thing about
that poll uh Greg is that most voters
don't want Trump or Biden which I think
we're going to find uh in that poll you
showed with the other candidates uh
they're all polling pretty closely uh or
a little ahead I think Rama Swami was
behind DeSantis was taught and the
others were ahead and Nikki Haley who I
thought had a really good debate uh is
obviously continuing to re-benefit from
that two I think as you think about the
issues I think one of the things
whomever the Republican might be and
whoever the Democrat might be and I
don't I think that the more these things
come out about President Biden in the
coming weeks and months uh the Whitmer
name the Newsome name and other names
you're going to continue to hear
populate the field
I think two issues are going to really
help voters decide how they're going to
pick a candidate one is abortion uh and
we uh Justin I go back and forth and
we've joshed each other here on the show
a little bit but and that's because the
way I said it Republicans got to get
right on this issue to be I think
competitive nationally uh in this
presidential race because I think the
question will be asked of whomever the
nominee is on either side will you
appoint justices or judges who come down
on one side or the other and people can
decide what they want but the voters are
telling us in conservative States and
moderate States and liberal states that
they want more they want more openness
on this issue two the issues of crime
and Border uh Republicans are at an
advantage on that versus Democrats so
we'll be I think those three issues will
be the issues that decide for many many
Americans and from as we think about
identity and identification and culture
going forward and if I were someone
thinking about running for president or
running for president I would be
thinking very seriously about how I
confront these issues and how I talk
about them in the Battleground States
getting closer did you hear that Jesse
did you hear that what he just said he's
moving closer screw Newsome I'm going to
send you a check yeah me too I don't
think we're allowed to but I will I'll
give him cash too you know Jesse the
whole thing is like you notice that you
know obviously Biden has a million
negatives he has more negatives than an
electron slumber party yes but it
doesn't matter because the media is just
going to let them fly anyway it's like
nobody really has a choice I don't know
about that CNN looks like they want
Trump I can tell they're pushing Biden
out so fast he doesn't even know what's
hit him think about it the quality of
life in this country has eroded under
Joe Biden they're talking about bringing
asks back Greg yes you you the border is
a mess it's killing wages because of the
illegals inflation's chewing up your
paycheck and food's expensive steak and
eggs are off the charts breads off the
charts you can't go out to eat not only
can't yeah buy a house you can't build
one because Lumber and construction
costs you can't rent because the rent's
too damn High where have we heard that
before so it's an absolute joke when you
walk outside when you have crime and you
have a guy bragging about infrastructure
the only thing he's broken ground on is
he's building an anti-racist bird
watching bridge in Arizona I mean get
out of here with that everyone is
leaving Democrats Independents blacks
Hispanics young people they don't like
the guy no they should be racist
he's catch it on yeah I like this
it's he's got problems big problems oh
man what might stance on masks only for
the unattractive
I want you to subscribe to the next News
YouTube page this
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now